[Applaudissements]
ce jour-là sur la plage ça a changé ça tu
veux te venger ce que tu penses que tu
vas sauter de cellule en cellule en éliminant des
terroristes
pour commencer toi ce que je veux que tu connaisses
ma discussion c'est un guerrier parmi les
meilleurs  J'ai toujours su que ce sont de mauvaises choses et
toi maintenant tu veux aller tuer des terroristes
pas là-bas c'est à propos de la mission
pas à propos de toi sympa et puis frappe juste
ici comme si ce
test sur le toit était hors du tableau que
j'ai déjà vu hors du tableau  pas comme
ça tu penses que tu es spécial ne le laisse
jamais devenir personnel il y a six jours 15 kilos de
plutonium ont disparu ce que ça ne peut pas être
lui
c'est un fantôme pourquoi j'ai juste pour toi quelque
chose de personnel
tout ce que tu as fait je lui ai appris je vais  faites-
le où est votre équipe où devriez-vous en
avoir besoin
ce n'est qu'un moyen d'arriver à vos fins ce
n'est pas maintenant
ce n'est que le début